From the creators of The Last Airbender
comes the story of a new generation what
makes you so sure your daughter is the
one
that was a 2000 year-old historical
treasure whoops it's time for your
generation to take on the responsibility
of keeping peace and balance in the world
your best friend is a polar bear-dog
somehow that makes perfect sense who do
you think you are why don't you come and
find out
the era of bending is over
Republic city does need you but it needs
me too
I will destroy you I've never felt like
this before I don't know what to do it's
okay to be scared
there's no place in the world for you anymore
don't count us out just yet the legend of korra
Welcome back everyone is Charlie big
surprise Netflix just made a big
announcement about the future of the
avatar series we have the new Avatar The
Last Airbender series that Mike and
Brian are doing the brand-new episodes
that will probably be coming late next
year early 2021
but Netflix also announced that all the
chorus stuff is now coming to Netflix too
previously was just the classic series
since they're doing a brand new version
of the classic series a lot of you've
also asked me if they would do the same
thing for Legend of Korra after that
because there's only three books worth
of episodes for the classic series so
I'll explain what Mike and Bryan have
said about that and other future
animated projects it'll explain what
happened to team aang between the events
of avatar the last airbenders finale
sozin's comet in the beginning of korra
season 1 because it's over 70 years
worth of history and they've really only
glossed over that so far like what
happened to Aang how did he die what
happened to the rest of the squad
because some of the older team aang
members like Zuko Toph and Katara did
show up in the core episodes so starting
with number 5 the first thing that
happened to team avatar right after the
finale was Zuko was crowned Fire Lord
and you have the events of the promise
comic book it takes place just a little
while after the events of the finale so
not a lot of time has gone by the
promise title is a reference to the
promise that Aang and Zuko make to
ensure that something like the hundred
year war with the Fire Nation never
happens again in the symbol of that
promise eventually becomes Republic City
as you see it during Legend of Korra now
it took a long time to build that city
but eventually they pick a site it's
meant to be this neutral sort of
territory between all the nations and
kingdoms where the world lives in
harmony at least that was the idea when
they started building it for everyone
that saw the Korra episode there's an
awful lot of war that happens inside
Republic City for it to be this peaceful
place that I intended it to be but
during this period in history there's a
couple skirmishes and border tensions
between the Fire Nation and other
kingdoms because the wars only just
ended so tempers are pretty high Zuko
goes to see his father Fire Lord Ozai
while he's in prison they talk about the
fate of his mother he gets some details
about what happened to her they just
leave him to question what really
happened you also find out what happened
to Azula right after the finale she got
locked up for her own safety mostly
because she went completely crazy during
the
the finale after the Agni Kai still
super crazy that doesn't change in toff
starts her metalbending school that will
eventually evolve into the metalbender
city within the earth Kingdom where her
future daughter suyin will live but Toph
is canonically the first human
metalbender in the avatar universe that
we know about so she gets full credit
for inventing metalbending number 4 that
a little bit of time goes by and you
have the events of the search comic book
the title of the search is a reference
to Zuko's search for his mother they
eventually do find her in Azula uses the
opportunity to go with them and escape
so she goes off into the wild and is
running around the world but initially
what happened is is that Zuko as a child
believe that his mother abandoned them
and he and Azula grew up thinking that
she didn't love them and he just
believed what he was told I think that
was just to make his backstory as sad as
possible
growing up believing that his mother
didn't love him what they find is is the
true story behind IRS's disappearance
that's the name of Sukkos mother is that
she didn't abandon her children she was
forced to leave is because in the past
she learns that Fire Lord Ozai father
fire lord azulon had actually ordered
Ozai to kill Zuko his punishment for
Ozai asking to be made heir to the
throne following the death of iroh's son
in the siege of Ba Sing se everyone
cried a little bit and think about
leaves on the vine she discovers that
Ozai was going to comply with as laws
demand because he wanted to be Fire Lord
no matter what in order to save Zuko's
life his mother offers to provide Ozai
with an untraceable poison which he
could use to kill özil on his father and
then become Fire Lord that way Ozai
agrees on the condition that Ursa would
leave the city and never return so that
nobody could find out that he secretly
killed his father
the second condition was that Ozai
forced Ursa to leave Azula and Zuko
behind without giving her the
opportunity to tell them why she was
leaving the noza would keep them close
to him as hostages as collateral against
her should she ever try to come back in
out him for what he did
Zucco's eventually reunited with her
they find out that she'd actually used
the mother of faces ability to literally
change her face and erase her memories
of the past so that she could start over
completely with the new life is someone
different she eventually got remarried
she's living a happy life when Zuko
finds her but she agrees to get her
memory
back from the mother of faces then once
she does and she remembers Zucco she
apologizes to him for letting him
believe that she'd abandoned him they
reconcile and she continues to live her
new life with Zuko going back to the
Fire Nation understanding that she still
loves him so they get sort of a happy
ending and then during the smoke and
shadow they addressed what happened to
Azula after she escaped she continues to
grow up but comes back to harass Zuko
every once in a while trying to make him
more and more hardcore become
quote-unquote the Fire Lord she knows
that he can be the number three we
learned what happened to Toph who went
on to have two daughters from two
different men her older daughter Lin
beifong and younger daughter suyin
beifong both big characters during
Legend of Korra we only learned the
identity of Lin's father in the fact
that soohyun's father was a different
man a lot of people had wondered if
Sokka ever got together with Toph and
was one of her baby daddies just because
there was some implied chemistry between
them in the original series some
shipping moments but they never fully
answered that question so neither Lin
nor soohyun know their fathers growing
up tops first husband was actually an
earthbender named Kanto who died when
she was pregnant with Lin then several
years later she has a relationship with
another mystery man getting pregnant
with suyun but the way that Toph
explains it in her old age is that that
man left her just because he couldn't
deal with it Mike and Bryan haven't
revealed who the second baby daddy was
but a lot of people want to believe that
it's Sokka in in present-day his
whereabouts are still kind of
unconfirmed you don't find out how he
died but Katara implies that he might be
dead so it is possible this Sokka really
is su Ian's father but that would mean
that Toph was lying to her daughters
talking about him as a man quote/unquote
who left her when she was pregnant
because Sokka would never leave Toph
when she was pregnant
now if Sokka were to die while Toph was
pregnant and he did have that child with
her that's a different matter but the
comics haven't fully answered that
question yet so you're still kind of
left to wonder number two Aang and
Katara started their family having three
children tenzin bumi and kya all really
big legend of korra characters kya was a
waterbender Tenzin was an airbender and
when he was old enough because he was
the oldest child he actually got to
travel the world with Aang while he was
an adult as the avatar just putting out
fires all over the world
Bumi he didn't
manifest any airbending powers till late
in his life so when he was younger he
joined the military eventually became a
general but then retired to live with
his family
then when all the airbenders started
manifesting during Korra book 3 he gets
airbending abilities too and officially
joins the new airbending nation the
reason that aang died so young though he
died when he was around 66 biologically
not that old he died because of the
physical toll being in the Avatar State
for over a hundred years took on his
body when he was stuck in the ice so you
have to remember that chronologically he
died when he was a hundred and sixty-six
years old his body just gave out from
being so taxed but number one I know a
lot of you are also asking me will they
do a new live-action Legend of Korra
after the new live-action Avatar The
Last Airbender Netflix series that
they're making right now my assumption
is that Netflix wants to use this as
their big game of Thrones level
programming their big Disney Plus killer
so they probably want as much new avatar
as possible and Mike and Bryan implied
that there might also be future animated
projects set in the Avatar universe so
it's not that they're just doing this
new live-action avatar the last
airbender series there might also be
more animation in the distant future
because it's taken them years to develop
just this first live-action Avatar The
Last Airbender series if they do
eventually do live-action and Korra that
would probably be way way down the road
in any new animation projects would be
after that too so for at least the next
several years is just going to be about
this brand new avatar the last airbender
Netflix series but if you have any other
questions about the avatar lore or any
bonus videos that you want me to do just
let me know in the comments I did do a
lot of Legend of Korra episode videos
but it was way back when I first started
my channel so the videos seem very
different from the type of videos that I
make now you can click here for all my
avatar the last airbender videos and my
Legend of Korra episode videos and click
here for that new Spider Man into the
spider-verse 2
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!